Hello, everyone and welcome to
today's live broadcast,
Advances in Cellular Automation
presented by Mike Kowalski, PhD.
We are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar
presented by LabRoots.com,
the leading social media site
for science professionals,
and sponsored by
Beckman Coulter Life Sciences.
Beckman Coulter Life Sciences
develops, manufactures, and markets
products that simplify,
automate, and innovate
complex biomedical testing.
More than 275,000
Beckman culture systems
operate in both diagnostics
and life sciences laboratories
in seven continents.
For over 75 years,
our Beckman's products have been
making a difference in people's lives
by improving the productivity
of medical professionals and scientists,
supplying critical information
for improving patient health
and delivering trusted solutions
for research and discovery.
To learn more about Beckman
Coulter Life Sciences,
please visit
www.beckman.com.
I am Judy O'Rourke of LabRoots
and I'll be your moderator
for today's event.
Before we begin,
I would like to remind everyone
this event is interactive.
We encourage you to participate
by submitting as many
questions as you want
at any time you want
during the presentation.
Just click on the green Q & A button
located in the lower left of
the presentation window,
type your question into the box
that appears on the screen.
We'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation.
Also, please notice
you'll be viewing the
presentation in the slide window.
To enlarge this window,
just click on the screen icon
located on the lower right.
And finally, if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation,
please click on
the support button
at the top right of the
presentation window.
Or you can use the Q & A button
to let us know that
you're having a problem.
Thank you.
Now I'd like to introduce
Dr. Kowalski.
Mike Kowalski is a staff
application scientist
in sample preparation in
applied markets group of
Beckman Coulter Life Sciences.
He received his PhD in Microbiology
and Molecular Genetics
from Harvard University.
Prior to joining Beckman,
Dr. Kowalski was a post-doctoral fellow
at the Novartis Institute
for Biomedical Research,
where he used automation
to screen for novel regulators of stem
cell potency and differentiation.
Since joining Beckman, Mike has
developed automated applications
in the areas of cell culture,
cellular analysis,
and mass spectrometry.
Please join me in
welcoming Dr. Kowalski.
I will now turn the
presentation over to him.
Thank you, Judy,
for the introduction,
and thank you everyone
for attending today.
As Judy mentioned,
I'll be talking
about some of the work we've done
to automate cellular applications
using our new Biomek i-Series.
Before we begin, we do have
a few disclosures to show,
and we'll now move on to
the actual talk itself.
So this webinar is part of a
series that have been presented.
With the earlier talks having described
how the Biomek i-Series can provide
simplicity, efficiency,
adaptability, and reliability.
For those who were unable to
attend the earlier talks,
I'll just give a brief overview of
the Biomek i-Series instruments.
But mostly we'll focus on
how this simplicity, efficiency,
adaptability, and reliability
can be applied to a variety
of cellular workflows,
including ELISAs, flow
cytometry, pull prep,
transfection optimization,
and basic cell culture.
So for the brief introduction,
the i-Series come in two
different formats -
the i5, shown on the left,
has a single pod
which can either have
a multichannel head,
such as a 96 or a 384 head,
or it can have a Span-8 pipetters,
which each of the
probes can spread out,
allowing you to
access multiple tubes at once.
Shown on the right
is the Biomek i7.
This can have up to two heads,
so it can have either a single
multichannel or a single Span-8 head,
or it can have dual
multichannels or one of each -
a Span-8 and a multichannel.
It obviously has a larger footprint
than the i5 shown on the left.
Some of the new features that
are shown on the i-Series
include a status light, shown at the
top of the enclosure to the right.
This light can basically indicate what
is happening while on the system,
whether it's currently running, whether
it needs to have an interaction,
or whether it's in standby mode.
And there's also a new deck LED light,
which helps illuminate the
deck for configuring the deck,
as well as just keeping
an eye on what's happening.
However, this light can be turned off
if you're working with
light-sensitive reagents.
There's also an optional
enclosure shown to the right,
and this very useful for
cell culture applications
because it can be configured
with HEPA filtered fans
to ensure a sterile
working environment.
It also can enable direct integrations,
also shown to the right,
and we'll cover a number
of these throughout the talk,
whether it be plate readers,
incubators, flow cytometers, etc.
Both of the instruments
have a configurable high-density deck,
shown on the lower left.
The Biomek i5 deck has up to
25 microtiter plate positions.
And the i7 has up to
45 microtiter plate positions.
These can be
configured in different ways
with different positions
for heating and cooling,
for trash or washes, etc.
And each of the systems features
a high-axis rotating gripper.
This allows complete
coverage of the deck
so that all positions can
be accessed.
And because of the high access,
you can also pick up a microtiter plate
next to a taller piece of labware,
such as a tip box.
There's one per head,
so if you have two
heads on the system,
you would have two grippers.
When it comes to liquid handlers,
obviously, liquid handing
is still the key,
so we have made some improvements
to the multichannel head.
One of the main features is
that there's now a 1,200
microliter capacity head.
This enables you to
transfer one mil per tip
while also having a 20 percent
additional blowout
to ensure all the liquid
is removed from the tips.
And the head now
features selective tip pipetting,
so enabling you to pick up
a single column, a single row,
or a single tip or any
combination of tips as needed.
This obviously gives
a lot more flexibility
than being forced to always use
96 or 384 tips at once.
On the Span-8 side, we now
have per probe calibration.
So obviously, we know there may be
some slight inherent
differences between the pumps,
so this really enables you
to dial in the accuracy
of the low end if needed.
So obviously, having the ability
to calibrate each probe
can really provide some of
that additional precision.
And also, from a simplicity standpoint,
we now have a volume spitting feature,
that all you have to do
is check a check box,
and if you ask to transfer a volume
that is more than the tip capacity
or the head capacity,
the Biomek will do the calculations
and split it into the number of
transfers needed to reach that volume.
We also have a deck
observation system.
This basically entails
two wide-angle cameras,
one on each of the
front corners of the system.
This can enable remote monitoring.
Obviously, for longer work loads,
you may not necessarily want to
stay by the instrument,
so this allows you to monitor
what's happening on the instrument from
your desktop or your laptop computer.
Another feature is that it
will record 30 seconds on both
before and after any error that occurs.
Obviously, a good way to troubleshoot
if something has gone wrong.
We also offer the PROService
Remote Management System.
This can actually allow our tech support
folks to access some of the error logs
or possibly look at some of
those minute long videos
to try to get an idea of what, if any,
maintenance is needed for the system.
And this should enable them to
bring the parts they would need
to help save an additional trip.
And finally, the system
is Windows 10 compatible,
which is great for moving forward
as more and more instruments
will be running on Windows 10.
So moving now into
the cellular applications.
We'll start out with an ELISA method.
I think most people are
familiar with ELISAs.
It's obviously pretty ubiquitous.
It is a fairly labor-intensive
process though,
and shown on the lower left hand side
is just a workflow that we
use for our proof of principle work.
This was an IL-22 ELISA kit that
was just commercially available.
And the steps include
doing a serial dilution,
using the automation,
and then adding a diluent and the
samples and standards to the plate,
shaking it for two hours,
doing four washes,
adding a conjugate to the plate, and
then shaking for another two hours,
followed by additional washes,
and then a 30-minute incubation
with a substrate,
adding a stop solution,
and then reading absorbents.
So a fairly straightforward workflow,
but again, one that if done manually
can essentially take the good
portion of the day
and just requires quite
a number of liquid transfers.
Shown on the lower right hand
side is the deck of the i5.
If you wanted to use
fresh tips for each transfer,
you can see very quickl
how the deck fills up,
and this is one of the advantages
of the high capacity deck,
is that we're able to incorporate all
this labware during the workflow.
Another one of the
challenges for ELISAs is
that it's frequently very
highly variable in throughput.
The same workflow can be used
for assaying 8 to 24 samples,
or it could be a much higher
throughput type of application
where you're screening for
IGD producing clones,
where it can be in the hundreds
to thousands of samples.
We'll keep this in mind as we
talk about more of the workflow.
So for the proof of principle,
we used the Biomek i5's Span-8
system, shown to the right.
We were able to process a full
plate in six and a half hours.
And obviously, using the Span-8 system,
this would be more of a low
to medium throughput,
probably one to two
plates a day.
Of that six and a half hour workflow,
four and a half hours were just
straight incubations.
And obviously, when
we do ELISAs manually,
typically this involves
adding wash buffer
and inverting the plate over some waste
and shaking it out
and blotting it against a pad.
This is not something that's
very automation friendly,
so to ensure that we have removed
all the liquid from the plates,
we use our optimized
by pipetting techniques
to aspirate around the
circumference of the well,
sort of at the north, south,
east, and west quadrants,
and just ensure that we were
able to remove
all the liquid
from the flat bottom wells.
We were able to achieve
excellent standard curves
as shown by the precision of our -
the reproducibility of
our triplicate values
on our standard curves shown on
the lower left hand side,
where all the CVs of our
replicates were under five percent.
And we also had excellent linearity
as indicated by R² value
of .991 for our standard curve,
indicating our automated serial
dilution was highly effective.
So this is a fairly
straightforward application,
but if you want to do those types
of higher throughput applications
that I mentioned earlier,
such as clone screening,
there are a number of considerations
when moving to that higher throughput.
The first is that you'll likely need
to move to a multichannel system.
The nice thing with having
the selective tip feature
is that even if you're only
assaying 24 or 8 samples,
this still can be done
using the multichannel head
using the selective tip feature.
Another consideration is deck space.
As I showed before, this
could require a lot of tips,
a lot of buffers or reservoirs,
that's for a single plate.
So if you have additional plates,
having the higher deck capacity
of an i7 might be valuable,
or you might need to integrate
some additional storage positions,
and we have labware feeders
that will allow you
to have lots of tips or plates
available for a higher throughput.
Another consideration is dead volume.
Obviously, if you're using a
multichannel reservoir,
the dead volume for those are
roughly 20 mils,
which could obviously be more
than you would have available
for some of the reagents
such as antibodies,
but wash buffer etc
might be very plentiful.
So you would need to consider
the balance between speed
and throughput
versus how much reagent
you have available.
And again, using the selective
tip feature,
you could go ahead and use that
for the antibodies well
using all 96 channels for the wash.
Another consideration is scheduling.
Obviously, if you're processing
multiple plates
and if you want to compare those
results across the plates,
you need to ensure you
have consistent timing.
This may not be so essential
for two hour incubation,
but some of those substrate
incubations at the end of the ELISAs
may call for only five to ten minutes,
possibly as low as two minutes,
before you are required to
add your stop solution,
and for this, you obviously want
to put some timing constraints in,
and that's one of the nice features
of our SAMI EX scheduling software,
shown on the lower right hand corner.
You can allow the software
to try to schedule the plates
as efficiently as possible,
but for some of those critical steps,
you are able to put in constraints
and ensure that each plate
is treated consistently.
So moving on now to flow
cytometry sample prep.
There are a number of
challenges to consider
when preparing samples for
flow cytometry analysis.
The first main consideration is that
you require single cell suspensions.
If you're working with
an inherent cell line,
this requires a trypsinization step.
Now typically cells may often cluster
together during trypsinization,
and this is when it's essential
to have something like
the multichannel head,
where it can do repeated
pipetting up and down
to ensure that those
clumps are broken
into the single cell
suspensions that you require.
Another consideration is
sample throughput,
and a lot of this will be
determined by your flow cytometer.
If your flow cytometer takes single
tubes or a carousel of tubes,
your throughput will likely be lower
than if your cytometer can acquire
samples using a plate-based format.
However, we do have automated solutions
for both of those types of workflows.
And in fact, you may be able
to process your samples in plates
and then do a final transfer to tubes
if your cytometer requires it.
Another consideration is
that most of the workflows
for flow cytometry,
such as antibodies sustaining workflows,
require a centrifugation step
to pellet the cells
in allowing you to
perform reagent exchanges
such as antibody washes.
Another consideration is that most
of the reagents are fluorescent,
so this typically means
they are light sensitive,
so you need to consider
how long you're able to leave your
reagents on the deck of your instrument.
And we'll talk about each of these
requirements as we go forward.
For our proof of principle experiments,
we basically wanted to perform
a drug discovery screen.
So for this, we used three
inducers of apoptosis
and screened two different
cancer cell lines
to look at their effectiveness
both using dilution curves
- so looking at different
concentrations of the drugs,
and also looking at their effects
over multiple time points.
We used one adherent and
one suspension cell line,
the HC116 colon carcinoma cells
were adherent,
and the Jurkat leukemia cell
line was our suspension example.
As I mentioned before,
the HCT116 cells required
that repeated pipetting
using the multichannel head
during the trypsinization step
to ensure we had single cells.
We then stained the cells
with markers for apoptosis
using a fluorescent
caspase 3/7 substrate,
and we also added a DRAQ7 cell
impermeable nuclear dye
as an indicator of cell death
looking for compromised cell membranes.
We then acquired our data
using the CytoFLEX flow cytometer
and the system we used can acquire
15 parameters in 10 colors,
although there are now even
better versions of this
I think that go up to 20 or so colors.
The nice thing about the CytoFLEX
is that it can accommodate
either tubes or plates,
and obviously we went with the
plates loader for our work today.
We then did the analysis using
our Kaluza G software.
We'll now show a brief video
that will illustrate some of the
early portion of the workflow
where we focus on the
treatment of the cells.
This video will demonstrate
our automated flow cytometry workflow,
specifically the initial compound dilution
and treatment of our
cell culture plate.
Shown here, the Span-8
system has loaded seven tips
and is transferring our drug diluent
into a plate that currently has
the highest concentration of
our compounds in the top row.
For this demonstration, we
are testing three compounds,
so we will have a final dose
response curve of 24 wells each
with eight dilutions
of three compounds.
Following this transfer, one of
the new features of the i-Series
is having a universal tip type.
These tips can then be shared
between both the Span-8 pod
and the multichannel pod,
which is very beneficial when
only using partial tip boxes.
Shown next is the selective tip
feature of the multichannel head,
enabling us to load just three tips,
which will then be used to do
a row-wise dilution
in a 1:1 fashion of our three compounds.
Once the serial dilution is complete,
as mentioned, we will
have 24 total wells,
eight different concentrations
of three compounds.
We then load 24 tips
using the selective tip feature
on the multichannel head,
and these compounds will then
be stamped into the cell plate
shown in the position behind it.
By doing this repeated stamping,
not only are we able to do
dose response curves,
we're also able to establish
a time course of treatment
by just processing partial plates.
So now we'll look at
some of the data.
Again, this was the HCT116 cells,
so following the
treatment of the cells,
we then automated the trypsinization
using the same 24 tips in
the selective tip fashion,
and then added our staining
reagents and did our analysis.
So looking here,
we're looking at a single time
point of 48 hours after treatment,
and shown on the X-axis is
our caspase 3/7 staining,
and on the Y-axis is
our DRAQ7 staining.
We basically picked just three
out of our eight treatments,
so we're representing a high, medium,
and low concentration of our compounds.
In this particular case, we're
looking at 5-fluorouracil treatment.
And what you can see is,
as you decline from
the highest concentration
to the lowest concentration,
the number of cells found in the
dead and apoptotic gates decease,
indicating our serial dilution
was effective.
In fact, we can actually plot
some nice dose response curves
with all of the data that we achieved.
What you can see is that looking
at this HCT116 cell line at 48 hours,
we see that staurosporine and
camptothecin were far more effective
at killing these cells
than 5-fluorouracil.
Looking at the IC50
concentrations
of 63 nanomolar, 317 nanomolars,
roughly a thousand fold more
effective than the 368 micromolar
required to get 50 percent cell
death in this HCT116 cell line.
So again, a nice illustration
of a dose response,
but we also want to look
at different time courses.
Shown here is our Jurkat cell line.
Again, the suspension cell lines.
There's no trypsinization required.
We simply added our
reagents and did our analysis.
This was looking at a single
concentration of camptothecin treatment
at 78 nanomolar.
And what you can see is, over time,
the untreated cells shown in the
viable gate in the lower left quadrant,
after 24 hours, move
into the apoptotic quadrant,
so they're staying positive for
caspase 3/7.
Still very few are seeing for DRAQ7.
And then with an additional
24 and 48 hour treatments,
you see more and
more percentages of the cells
moving into that dead quadrant
in the upper right hand quadrant.
This can also be plotted out
and what you can see
is a corresponding decrease
in the viable cell count at 24 hours
with an increase in the
apoptotic cells,
followed by a subsequent decease
in the apoptotic cells
with an increase in the
number of dead cells.
Again, a nice illustration
of time dependent responses
in this particular cell line
as shown by flow cytometry.
There's some additional consideration
when thinking about flow cytometry.
We've already touched on
some of them.
Some of the workflow will be
determined, again,
by the flow cytometer
if you require tubes or plates.
So it's nice to have the
Span-8 pod working with tubes.
Again, the entire workflow can be
processed in tubes using the Span-8,
or like I mentioned before,
you could actually do the
processing on a plate
and do a final transfer
with the Span-8 into the tubes
in a very rapid fashion.
It's certainly useful to have
that multichannel head
for the resuspension of adherent
cells if that's required.
But again, if folks are working
on blood samples etc,
that might be less of a consideration.
What we showed today was
a relatively simple example
of just an add and read type of assay.
However, most of the more
typical workflows
would require antibody staining and
just more of a complex sample prep,
requiring washes and reagent exchanges.
These types of workflows
can definitely be aided by integrations.
And shown on the lower right hand
side, we did have an i5 system
that we demonstrated the integration
of the CytoFLEX itself.
So if you're processing
large numbers of samples,
the integration allows the analysis
to begin right at the completion
of sample preparing
without any intervention.
We also, kind of on the right
hand side of that image,
you can see a microplate centrifuge
that can be directly
integrated onto the deck.
Again, this is excellent
for the spin down
and wash steps for those
antibody type protocols.
We also have the option to
integrate a plate washer,
if this would help assist things.
However the multichannel can essentially
do most of this workflow by itself
with the addition and
removal of washes, etc.
There's also the ability
to integrate incubators,
either something small shown
as the single plate incubator
next to the CytoFLEX in the image,
or much larger, higher capacity
incubators such as a Cytomat 2 C.
This would be good for, say,
long-term staining
or just similar treatments like we had
where you would treat cells
with compounds, let them incubate,
then bring the cells back up from
the incubator and do your staining.
Once again, I've already
mentioned our SAMI EX software.
This software would also be useful
for this type of application,
for these higher throughput methods
where, again, it could process
multiple plates in staggered fashion.
Once again, you can put in those
type of timing constraints
for the steps that are essential.
One example would be trypsinization.
Obviously, you want to
consistently treat your plates
because if you have longer
trypsinization times,
this can actually change the cell
surface expression of some proteins
as more of them get cleaved during
longer trypsinization treatments.
So I'll now move onto another example,
being transfection optimization.
When I think of transfection,
it seems relatively simple.
Essentially it's just combining
a lipid with a nucleic acid
and putting that
on top of cells.
However, it's not necessary
simple for every cell type.
Because of this, an optimization
approach can help.
Unfortunately, optimizing transfection
conditions is not so simple.
For this example, we chose
to use a design of experiment,
or a DOE approach
where we changed the different
lipids we were using,
we tried different lipid concentrations,
different concentrations
of nucleic acids,
and different cell numbers
to see if we could identify
an optimal condition
for a variety of different
cell lines.
The problem with this approach, or
the difficulty with this approach,
is that, first off, from an
automation perspective,
you need ways to
create these combinations,
and again, this is a nice example
of how having the selective tip
feature for the multichannel head
really enables some of these
because you can do
row-wise or column-wise transfers
as well as any
combination you might need.
In addition, the other problem is that
the conditions increase bacterially.
So very quickly, as you add
more and more conditions,
the number of
samples you need to test
grow pretty dramatically very quickly,
and we'll show an
illustration of that as well.
So the workflow that -
the approach that we took to automating
the transfection optimization is
we started with an empty plate,
and then tried six different
lipid conditions,
really five different commercial
lipids that were available,
DharmaFECT one
through four and Lipofectamine,
and one condition that had no lipids,
so essentially, our
untransfected control.
We used our Span-8 system
to transfer these reagents from tubes
into the upper row of the 96 well plate,
and then also used the Span-8
to just fill in the next 18 wells
with media for serial dilutions.
Shown with the dark and light
purple, we also used the Span-8
to transfer two different
concentrations of our nucleic acid.
We did an siRNA control.
On the next step,
we loaded six tips on our
multichannel selective tip,
much like you saw earlier
with the three tips
for the flow cytometry example,
and we did a serial dilution
in a row-wise fashion
to get 24 different
conditions of lipids,
and then stamp those into the
lower 24 wells using the same six tips.
We then used our Span-8
at the same time
to essentially stamp out
those nucleic acids
into the remaining 48 wells
on the right hand side.
We then loaded 48 tips on
the multichannel selective tip
and combined those 48 wells on the
left to the 48 wells on the right,
resulting in 48 different conditions of
nucleic acid and lipid combinations.
Following an incubation
to allow for transfection
complexes to form,
we then stamped those 48
conditions into a 384 well plate,
and then loaded 96 tips
to transfer two different
concentrations of cells,
resulting in 15,000 or 7,500
cells per well.
The final result was 96
different conditions -
and shown in the plate map below
- and the four blue wells indicate
the four replicate conditions
for a given condition,
such in this case was
.8 microliters of DharmaFECT 1
with 100 nanomolars of siRNA
and 15,000 cells per well.
So the nice feature here is
we're able to test 96
different conditions
in quadruplicate in
optimization in a single plate.
If we tried to do this manually,
my best estimate would be that it would
take about 138 manual transfers,
and instead, the automation was able
to achieve this in under 20 minutes.
We then tested this approach on
three different cell lines -
the HCT116 cells I've already
mentioned before,
and two additional cancer cell lines,
an ACHN line, which is renal carcinoma,
and PANC1 pancreatic
carcinoma cell line.
We used siGLO green as our
transfection marker.
This is a fluorescently labeled siRNA,
and 24 hours after transfection,
we added our same DRAQ7 reagent
as a marker for toxicity,
and then we performed media exchange,
using the multichannel head again
to try and reduce the amount of
background we got from the siGLO green.
We then did some imaging with
the SpectraMax i3X
with MiniMax 300 imaging cytometer
shown in the upper right.
This basically enables 4x images
to be taken in bright field in
two florescent wavelengths -
540 nanometers and 713 nanometers.
What this enables us to do
was to count total cells
and then get an idea of our
transfection efficiency
by counting the number of green cells,
indicating our siGLO
green had been taken up.
We also looked at toxicity,
so the number of red nuclei divided
by the total number of cells.
We looked at whether we had
either inhibited cell growth
or whether we had lost any cells
during our media replacement
by comparing our transfected
well to our untransfected wells
in the bright field images.
Then we also looked at
transfection consistency
by looking at the CVs across
our quadruplicate wells.
So no need to really look at the numbers
here but I'll basically summarize.
The first set of wells
on the left, green is good.
This is basically an indication of
getting over 30 percent transfection.
The next set of columns, red is bad.
This is basically any conditions
that resulted in toxicity more than
five percent above control wells.
The next set, brown is bad -
it's kind of difficult to see,
but again, this is where we had
less than 80 percent of our
untransfected cell counts in the well.
And then the final set of
columns, light green is good.
This is where our transfection
CVs were below ten percent.
So again, the take home message here is
we sort of identified
the best conditions
by the bold squares around those wells,
and the take home here is that
you can definitely see
that there are differences
across the three cell lines,
and we'll really identify
those in the next slide.
So shown here are the
resulting optimal conditions
for each of the cell lines,
and again, what you can quickly see
is that there are differences
between the cell lines.
All three of them had
different ideal lipids
that were used at
different concentrations,
different concentrations of siRNA.
But through optimization,
we were able to achieve roughly
50 percent transfection efficiency
with all three cell lines with
acceptable levels of toxicity,
and with CVs below ten percent.
Some of the cell lines,
like PANC1 and HCT116,
were relatively transfection friendly
in that there were a couple different
concentrations that might work.
But the ACHN cells
were significantly different and
really more troublesome to transfect,
and we did have to
find that optimal condition
to achieve that type of
transfection efficiency.
Some of the important take home
messages were that -
even a simple change.
Even just a twofold
change in lipid concentrations,
you'd see very dramatic effects.
Twofold too low and you would see
a very low transfection
efficiency, basically nothing.
Twofold too high and you would
see rampant toxicity
depending on your cell lines,
so really driving home the need to do
this type of optimization approach.
In addition, because we were
able to work in 384 well format,
this helped reduce our reagent usage.
So again, these are not
cheap reagents,
so obviously, the more you can do
in a smaller volume, the better.
But to try and do this manually,
this really adds challenge to this
because it's very difficult to tell
which wells you've added reagents to.
And another nice thing is now
that we have this automated approach,
it's very easily adapted
to different nucleic acids
or different assays.
So if you wanted to adapt this to
an overexpression type of assay,
just change the reagents,
possibly change your
transfection reagents
and add plasmids instead of
siRNAs and it should essentially work.
Alternatively, if you didn't want to
use a fluorescent siRNA as a marker,
instead you had some
phenotypic readout,
it might just be requiring changing
the assay approach at the end.
So now we'll sort of conclude with
basic cell culture approaches.
Again, this is not something
everyone thinks about automating
because it's something that was
typically done at the bench,
but this really is something that
can benefit from automation.
There's a number of reasons for that
because there are a number of challenges
associated with cell culture.
The first is that it's
basically very time-consuming.
And this can be because
it recurs frequently;
you're probably passaging cells
two to three times a week.
If you have multiple cell lines
going at the same time,
the throughput can become
really burdensome.
And it's relatively inflexible.
Cells don't really care if you
have an all-day meeting schedule.
If they're confluent,
they need to be passed that day.
In addition, there's high
variability in this type of work.
For example, sometimes
you just have cells
that you're waiting to plate
later in the week
and so maybe you don't have
that much work.
But Monday may look very
different than Thursday,
or this week may look
very different than next week.
In addition, we know
there are pepe in the lab
who passage cells differently than I do.
So for example,
we all sort of come up with our
own approach for passaging cells,
and it just depends
on how we were taught
or maybe what the written protocol says,
but we know there's inherent variability
in the way people do things.
By turning to automation,
this variability can go away
because a lot for the times,
this variability will show up
in your future assays.
And finally, it comes down
to scheduling as well -
when do I need cells?
When am I going to
plate my experiments?
When I'm doing multi-day workflows,
frequently some of these cell culture
assays may take days to weeks.
What planning ahead do I need to do
to ensure that I'm not here
all day on a weekend?
So these are just some
of the considerations
that can hopefully be
addressed through automation.
For the work we've done,
this will be done on an i7,
same as most of the work
has been done previously,
and it features a number of
integrations that we will show shortly.
The work we did involved just
culturally two adherent cell lines,
CHO cells, which we'll show
most of the data for,
as well as HCT116,
and a suspension cell
line, the Jurkat cells.
Basically, we're passaging
the cells in six well plates,
so large well plates to have enough
cells to plate for experiments.
We would pass a known cell
number every two to three days,
and then we would plate these cells
in either 96 or 384 well plates
for future assays
as a proof of principle.
The system itself utilized and
integrated Cytomat 2 C incubator
to allow us to culture
our cells directly
and bring them onto the system
in an automated fashion.
It also had an integrated bi-cell
XR cell viability analyzer,
shown on the right,
and this would enable us to
count our cells at time of passaging.
It also had a tilting
ALP for larger well plates
to basically allow the media
to slide all to one side
and enable us to remove that media
without disturbing the cells.
And we also had the
integrated SpectraMax i3X
with MiniMax that I mentioned earlier
and we used this for some imaging
and cell counting assays,
which we'll describe later.
Now we'll show a video,
again, that will really demonstrate
how this workflow proceeds
and how we utilize the different
integrated instruments.
So shown here is the automated approach
we took to automating cell culture,
starting from the larger six well plates
and moving assays into 96 well formats.
Shown here is the tilting ALP,
and the advantage of this is
that the media can be removed
from the edge of the well
without disturbing the
adherent cells on the well.
We used the Span-8 system
with a P1000
to reach into the corner
well and remove the media,
and then another P1000 tip to
dispense 800 microliters of trypsin
to remove the cells from
the surface of the plate.
This plate was then incubated at
37 degrees for five minutes,
and this was done on aesthetic Peltier,
but could've easily been done on
the integrated incubator as well.
We then used our optimized pipetting
to pipette around the
circumference of the well
to make sure the cells were removed
from the surface of the plate.
And then also did a mixing step
to ensure that the cells
were distributed
into a single cell suspension.
A portion of these re-suspended
cells were then added to the sample cup
for the integrated bi-cells
cell viability analyzer,
and the bi-cell returned a
viable cells per mil number,
which the Biomek was
automatically able to use
to calculate what volume of
cells needed to be transferred
to reach a certain number of cells.
If the volume was over one mil,
the capacity of the tip,
the split volume step
could be used
to automatically transfer
the larger volume.
In this case, we dispensed
one million cells
into the subsequent well
for continuing passages.
And a second subset of cells
was then added
to a large multichannel reservoir
containing 100 mils of media.
One of the advantages of
the large capacity multichannel head
is that we're now able to completely
mix these large volume reservoirs
and ensure the cells were evenly
distributed throughout the reservoir.
In addition, we were able
to increase the throughput
by using a multi-dispense feature,
allowing us to plate 496 well
plates with 200 microliters per well
in a single transfer step.
Again, this can be used to
increase the throughout
and process numerous
plates simultaneously
or process as many plates in a
subsequent fashion as needed.
So hopefully that gives you
a pretty good idea
of what the automation looks like
and what the workflow looks like.
We'll now look at some of the
data that came off this system.
So the first question is
just regarding the passaging
from one six well to another.
So all the work we'll
show here was done
using the Chinese hamster ovary
cells grown in adherent conditions.
Demonstrated here is basically the
results of one of our six well passages.
Shown below is basically taking
four regions of interest
and taking 12 images for each region,
using the SpectraMax MinMax imaging
cytometer 24 hours after plating.
And what you can see is that there's
no clumps of cells or no clusters,
so it looks like we had really
effective trypsinization in mixing,
and also, it looks very evenly
distributed across the four regions.
So what you can see on the left
is what I could achieve manually,
and on the right is what the system was
able to do in an automated fashion.
We got very comparable
percentages of confluence,
right around 60 percent,
and very low CVs in both cases,
indicating good dispersion
across the wells.
Looking across multiple passages now,
so shown here are basically
the automated comparison and manual
of what I was able to achieve.
And we look on the left
at cell counts,
and looking at how consistent
those were across passages
and also across
automation versus manual.
And on the right hand side
is plotting viability.
So we were able to achieve
consistently above 90 percent viability
in all six of our automated passages.
More interesting is that
actually if you look,
we were able to achieve results
that are more consistent
than I was able to achieve manually.
So again, looking at CVs of 7.9
percent in an automated fashion
when comparing cell counts
across six passages
was better than the 13.8 percent CVs
I was able to achieve manually.
We also noticed that there was
slightly less cells on average
in the automated well.
And that's likely because when we
have the plate in a titled fashion,
I can't actually angle the pipette
the way I can when I'm
performing it manually.
So there's that small five to ten -
probably five percent of the well
that may not necessarily get rinsed
down during the automated passage.
So we're likely plating
the same number of cells
and culturing the same number of cells,
but can't quite harvest
the same number of cells.
But again, we can do
this more consistently
and this consistency
can hopefully lead
to more consistent results
with our assays.
When it comes to actually plating,
the video demonstrated plating
into 496 well plates,
but we actually decided to
take it one step further
and try and plate into
two 384 well plates,
doing 100 microliters multi-dispenses,
much like we demonstrated in the video.
So again, 100 microliters
per well times 768 wells.
What we were able to see is that we
did, again, imaging after 24 hours.
We then looked to see,
did we get consistent distribution
of the cells across the plates?
So essentially, did our
mixing in the reservoir work?
Did we get roughly equivalent cells
in all regions of the plate?
[AUDIO CUTS]
Finally, we looked at how consistent
was our multi-dispense?
Basically, were we getting the same
number of cells for each dispense
in all of the eight quadrants?
And when we compared
the average counts per quadrant,
we saw CVs less than seven percent.
So again, a very consistent
passaging and plating,
hopefully resulting in
consistent assay results.
Another consideration that we touched
on earlier is multi-day workflows.
For example, we've just plated
our 96 or 384 well plates.
How long do these plates
need to incubate?
Is there an additional treatment?
How long until we assay them?
These things all have to be
taken into consideration
because very rarely is this
a single day approach.
So when automating these
types of approaches,
there's a number of requirements.
One main one is that
you need to have
good resource management
and scheduling,
and this comes back to
our SAMI EX software
where, again, when you're
processing multiple plates,
it will find the most efficient way
to process those plates
in badge-wise fashion.
It also requires sample tracking.
You need to know where your samples are
at any given time in the workflow.
And you also need to know
if your Biomek will be
available on a given day.
So if you have interleaved
multi-day workflows,
our SAMI process management software can
help fill these things on a calendar
so you can ensure that, again,
will you need to come in on a weekend?
Is the instrument already being
taken up for other assays on a given day?
And finally, you need
good data tracking,
and this is where our data acquisition
and reporting tool, DART,
comes into account.
Basically these types
of multi-day assays
may be made up
of little islands of automation
where you'll bring it in on day
zero, seed the cells,
send them to an incubator,
bring them back on day three,
treat them.
DART is basically our tool that
every time that play comes in,
it can read the barcode
and know everything that's been
done to that plate to date,
and all of that information is
carried forward,
so that eventually your treatment
and your eventual assay result
will all be located on the same
database on the same well.
So to wrap up the automated
cell culture portion of the talk today,
hopefully I've shown you
that we were able to handle
larger well plates and flasks
really using the span capabilities,
but having that
combination of pipetters.
The span for those six well
plates and the multichannel
for the micrometer plates
really is valuable for
this type of workflow.
There are some caveats.
One is that you may need
to do some optimization
for any given new cell line.
One example is the
frequency of passaging.
For example, when we were
passing the Jurkat cells,
we would pass them every two days
and they were completely happy.
The CHO cells, when we tried to
passage them every two days,
seemed to actually die off a little bit
and that's why we
batched it off to three days.
Another consideration is
the trypsinization workflows
for adherent cells.
One is just the trypsinization time.
Five minutes of incubation worked
great for the CHO cell lines,
but the HCT116 cells were
a little more aggregated,
so you might want to consider
extending that time closer
to seven to eight minutes.
In addition, the volume that you
transfer into the next well
is somewhat dependent
on just your cell size.
If you have a confluent
HCT116 well,
you can fit about five million cells
per well as opposed to the CHO cells,
where a confluent well
only had 2.5 times 10:6.
So if you were transferring a
million cells into the next well,
and you were concerned
about residual trypsin,
you're actually transferring twice the
amount of volume in the CHO cells
as you are on the HCT116.
So if you do find a need to either
spin out any of those reagents,
obviously there are some automated
solutions for that as well
and you can do media exchanges
and not have to worry
about residual trypsin.
And finally it comes down
to mixed steps as well.
As I mentioned, the HC116 cells
were a tale more clumping
than the CHO cell were
and so we basically increased the
number of mixes that we performed.
Another consideration is
the plating needs.
One of the nice features
of the Biomek is
that you're able to do
data-driven decisions.
For example, if your cells haven't grown
as much as you thought they might
and you're already in
the middle of passaging them,
you can actually just have
some if/then statements
indicating that if you don't have
a high enough number of cells
to do your cell plating,
you can just go ahead
and passage them
and push it off for another couple
days without wasting all the plastic.
So that basically kind of
wraps up the talk.
We'll bring it back
to the simplicity, efficiency,
adaptability, and reliability,
and see if we've hopefully
shown some examples
of how these apply
to cellular applications.
When it comes to simplicity,
having that volume splitting feature
where, again, it really doesn't
necessarily care
what the volume is
you need to transfer,
you don't necessarily need to put in
any sort of conditional
statements or scripting.
Whatever the results from
the bi-cell come back,
we can always just basically
have a transfer -
split the number of transfers it
needs to get the correct volume.
Also, having the integration,
we can be more direct.
Obviously, you can fit a lot of
instruments in a smaller footprint,
and not necessarily requiring
any additional robotic
transports to access these devices,
really increases the simplicity of
those types of integrated systems.
When it comes to efficiency,
we have the high capacity deck.
There's just more room,
more real estate to work with,
so you can really have these more
highly complex workflows as you need.
It can all fit potentially
on to the same deck.
And there's also the ability to
do the large volume transfer
so the multichannel head as we
demonstrated for the plating video.
And obviously, this can really just
make it a more efficient workflow;
you can process more plates
in a more rapid fashion.
When it comes to adaptability,
hopefully I've shown that
we were able to automate
a pretty diverse number of
workflows on the same system.
Really kind of indicating that,
yes, there really can be adapted
to pretty much any need you have,
and also the ability to use the
multichannel selective tip
really does increase the flexibility
of that multichannel head.
So again, you're able to do more
with that head alone.
And when it comes to reliability,
obviously having the remote monitoring.
Some of these cellular
applications, the ELISA in particular,
can take multiple hours.
So if you want to just be able to
check on your system,
it shouldn't still be running,
but again, being able to monitor
what's happening remotely
does provide you that
extra sense of security.
And having our PROService,
being able to access any sort of
error logs, or those video files,
really should be able to help
decrease any downtime
that the system might have.
So with that, I'll wrap up.
Obviously we have more
information available.
I've just kind of touched on
some of the applications,
but if you want more detail,
such as the volumes we were
using or the specific reagents,
that type of information can be
found in our application notes,
as well as a variety of other
resources that can be found
at biomek.beckman.com.
And with that, I'm happy to
take any questions.
Thank you, Dr. Kowalski, for
that informative presentation.
It is time for Q & A.
If you have a question you'd like
to ask Dr. Kowalski, please do so now.
Just click on the green Q & A button
at the lower left of the
Presentation window,
type your question into the
box that appears your screen,
and click on the Send button.
We'll answer as many questions
as we have time for.
The first question is,
"Have you successfully automated
cell culture without the titling
ALP by optimizing pipetting?"
That's a great question
and again, it might necessarily
depend on a given workflow.
For example, the large one well
plates, as they're called,
that would potentially be a little trickier
to kind of work our way around.
But the six well plate,
we are able to aspirate around
the circumference,
and that would be just as effective
way of removing the media
without disturbing the cells.
It might just take a little longer
to kind of execute that process.
So there's definitely a time and
a place for the tilting ALP
where it provides value,
but certainly not required for most
of the plates up to the very large,
maybe one well plates or,
for example, the auto-flasks,
which really only have a
single point of entry,
that's where, again, the
tilting ALP might be required.
Otherwise, it may just have
benefits for some of the plates,
but probably isn't necessary.
"How hard is it to adapt the
automation to different workflows?"
That's also a good question.
So the workflows I've shown today
were all done using the same deck,
but obviously it depends what
system you'd be working on.
Having the i7 hybrid sort of provides
you with the most flexibility,
but there are certain occasions where,
again, depending on your workflow,
if things are changing dramatically,
you can imagine possibly needed
to change what devices are
integrated to the system.
One of the nice things
on the i-Series is, again,
there's more universality
of the integration,
so those do become more easily
swapped in and out.
But when it comes to just changing the
positions on the deck, for example,
if you needed more heating and cooling
positions or more shaking positions,
or have some direct integrations
that change to your deck configuration,
that's very easily done.
That's basically just popping
out the current ALP positions,
putting on the next positions,
and then doing a quick auto frame
using our tools that are available.
When it comes to possibly
swapping out heads, for example,
you can change between the 96
and the 384 multichannel head.
That process is basically just
unscrewing four screws
and screwing them back in.
So even changing for that type
of workflow is very rapid.
It's basically built and designed to
have high levels of flexibility,
so again, barring some massive
reconstruction of your needs,
it should be very quickly able to
switch between workflows,
or otherwise you may be able
to just automate a number of workflows
on a single configuration.
"How do you handle contamination?"
So this comes up a lot, actually.
In seven years of doing this,
I've only run into it once,
and my way of dealing with it was to
throw out the contaminated plate.
I really didn't have any other problems.
That's kind one of the benefits
that, in theory, if things are
working right,
you shouldn't really be
spreading contamination,
so if you want to treat it
the way I would treat a
contaminated incubator,
you can spray things down with ethanol.
But just throwing away the
plate was sufficient for me.
I didn't really have any
continuing problems after that.
There was not really any
need to do anything extreme.
But there are certainly -
you know, we do have information
on chemical compatibility,
if people really need more
information about sterilization.
But honestly, for me, everything stays
pretty well-contained within the plate,
so throwing it out took care
of the problem.
As we're waiting for additional
questions to come in,
I would like to once again thank
Dr. Kowalski for his presentation.
Do you have any final comments?
Again, just want to thank
everyone for attending today.
Obviously, we're available for
additional information
when it comes to cellular workflows,
or my colleagues have presented on
some genomic workflows as well.
This is just one aspect of what
you can do with automation
and what you can do with
the Biomek i-Series,
so we're happy to always provide more
additional information as required.
Thank you.
I would also like to thank our sponsor,
Beckman Coulter Life Sciences,
for making today's educational
webcast possible.
Before we go, I want
to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing
through October 20, 2017.
You'll receive an email from LabRoots
letting you know when this will
be available for replay.
Please share that announcement
with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event.
That's all for now.
Thank you for joining us.
We hope to see you again soon. Bye.